two weeks of daily rallies have yet to
exhaust the energy of anti-government
protesters in colombia
as thousands took to the streets again
on wednesday
one rally in downtown bogota featured
union members
teachers and other workers on tuesday
president ivan duque offered further
concessions to lessen
people's outrage promising free tuition
for poor and working-class students at
public universities next semester
but protesters here say changes have to
be permanent
and remain skeptical of the government
promises
we don't trust the government they said
the same thing many times
last year they promised to get rid of
tuition but only 12
percent of poor students had access to
it the same with health reform the truth
is the government wants to fully
privatize health in the country
[Music]
kilometers away in another part of town
another massive
rally here the majority are taxi drivers
and students
the focus ending the brutal police
response to the protest
[Applause]
the official death toll of the past two
weeks rose past
40 but dozens more are missing
the truth is it's scary to come out and
protest but our desire for justice
to know the truth of the disappeared the
responsibility for the deaths
is bigger much bigger than the fear we
have
by the afternoon several rallies and
roadblocks paralyzed most of bogota
the mayor tweeted a map of the city's
public transport system
black highlights showing where service
was suspended
and authorities now also fear the
gatherings are increasing kov19
infections
as restrictions have become
unenforceable with daily massive
gatherings
cities across the country are now
bracing for a longer than expected
third peak of covid19 infections
more than 90 of intensive care units are
full
here in the capital bogota and the mayor
fears
a possible hospital collapse we are
concerned about the crowds at the
marches and protests
we ask the government and the leaders of
the strike to negotiate quickly
why to avoid further transmission of the
virus
we are facing a serious public health
problem mortality may increase
if the crowds continue but with
governments still resisting negotiating
the root causes of economic inequality
and refusing to condemn police violence
demonstrators promise
they will continue to protest alessandra
al jazeera